[Music]  ah  [Music]  [Music]  daddy  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  hey there townscapers it's scapegoat if  you hear my voice  then that means that you made it all the  way to the end of the video i want to  thank you so much for viewing  it's greatly appreciated please do not  forget to subscribe  when you subscribe you get notifications  for videos that i upload so you won't  miss a thing  please make sure you smack that like  button because when you do it helps me  out a lot  please share this video if you want to  that'll help me out too  you can also follow me on instagram the  link is in the description below  again i just want to thank you so much  for checking in with me and i'll see you  next time